Намагаючись переконати потенційних інвесторів у привабливості України,
український прем'єр-міністр Олексій Гончарук на Всесвітньому економічному форумі в Давосі
зробив гучну заяву щодо темпів зростання економіки України.
Якщо подивитися на цифри, на об'єктивні цифри, а вони не брешуть, -
то сьогодні ми зростаємо, наша економіка зростає швидше, ніж в середньому світ.
Сам Гончарук під час промови не назвав точний показник зростання.
У відкритих джерелах цієї цифри наразі теж немає.
Остаточну статистику за 2019 рік міжнародні установи опублікують лише влітку 2020-го.
Щоб перевірити правильність твердження українського прем'єра,
DW скористалась найактуальнішим прогнозом Світового банку,
який був оприлюднений у січні 2020 року.
Згідно з цим прогнозом, показник зростання валового внутрішнього продукту (ВВП) України
становить 3,6 відсотка.
Водночас у цілому в світі ВВП зріс лише на 2 з половиною відсотки.
Таким чином Олексій Гончарук має рацію
щодо швидкості темпів зростання української економіки у порівнянні з рештою світу.
Водночас, навіть якщо прем'єр оперував надійною статистикою,
його твердження правильне лише як констатація факту станом на даний момент.
Тобто показник зростання ВВП України нині вищий за середньосвітовий.
Це, однак, ще не дає підстав стверджувати про стрімкий економічний підйом або раптову
інвестиційну привабливість України,
як, наприклад, у випадку з Китаєм, Індією або Ірландією,
де зростання ВВП в останні роки - 6-7 відсотків на рік.
Незалежні економісти підтверджують тезу прем'єра про те, що в Україні панує
макроекономічна стабільність.
Вона є основою і для зростання.
Проте не можна розглядати економіку Україну в відриві від розвитку
глобальної та європейської економіки.
А кращі показники України є такими на тлі тенденційно не дуже добрих показникІв у світі.
Уже кілька років спостерігається погіршення глобальної кон'юнктури.
Це було, зокрема, і однією з головних тем щорічного форуму в Давосі.
Тривожна ситуація в провідних західних економіках - США та Німеччині.
Німецький ВВП торік зріс лише на піввідсотка.
Уряд побоюється економічної стагнації.
Для пожвавлення кон'юнктури Європейський центробанк
надає кредити банкам під рекордно низькі відсотки.
Тож за таких умов показники України - понад 3 відсотки росту -
не є приводом для великого оптимізму.
Крім того, темпи зростання української економіки залежать, зокрема,
і від збільшення обсягів експорту до Західної Європи.
І якби зростання там цілковито призупинилося, це позначилося б і на темпах українського зростання.
Ще одна важлива деталь: економісти у випадку України
часто згадують про так званий "ефект низької бази".
Слабкій економіці завжди є куди рости.
У 2014-му українська економіка обвалилась через початок збройного конфлікту на Донбасі.
Довоєнний обсяг річного ВВП, за даними Міжнародного валютного фонду,
дорівнював близько 180 млрд доларів США. 2019 року він становив близько 135 мільярдів доларів.
Тимчасово окуповані території - Крим і окремі райони Донбасу -
в українському валовому продукті наразі не враховують.
Твердження прем'єр-міністра Гончарука про те, що українська економіка зростає швидше,
ніж в середньому у світі, є правильним.
Однак саме по собі не може вважатися доказом успішності української економіки
та її привабливості для інвесторів.
Високий показник України необхідно розглядати в контексті.
Тим, що темпи зростання економіки України нині вищі світових, країна почасти завдячує тому,
що світова економіка розвивається дедалі повільніше.
Крім того, зростанню української економіки передувало значне падіння
у період з 2014 до 2016 року, коли вона знову стабілізувалася.